I am here cially and I'm a resident
fellow at the American Enterprise
Institute
I was not always a classical liberal I
would say from the time I started to
think independently of my parents but I
started out as a radical Islamic
fundamentalist then I came to the
Netherlands and I was very much taken
and I'm still impressed by the system
that the Dutch put in place I have now
come to see its weaknesses but I started
out as a Social Democrats after I
finished after I graduated from
University and it's only after in
politics when taking the theory of
politics it all added up it all made
sense it's only in practice that I
realized the like the weaknesses of
social democracy people become apathetic
depend on the government and the system
tends to be vulnerable when confronted
with external effects such as
immigration globalization and the system
tends them to become very weak
when I came to the Netherlands last time
I got a place to live I got my health it
was taken care of I mean I got so much
and I don't know how I would have
responded to the reality of the United
States where you have to you know do it
all by yourself
what are having having lived in Africa
having lived in the Netherlands and now
in the United States I think if you use
heterogeneity as a measure meaning the
mixture of people from many different
cultures different ages heterogeneity in
its most broad form that the American
system of free of a free market is not a
perfect system but is the best system
I don't see this crisis as anything that
will lead me to change my mind about the
superiority of the system of free
markets the alternative would be a
government-run and planned and planned
by the government look at Russia look at
the other by the way a number of other
European states in my country Holland
the government has kind of nationalized
all banks again it takes away the Dutch
participant in the market who was
irresponsible isn't going to be punished
as much as the American irresponsible
Wall Street trader and the difference is
the American economy will come out of
the slump at one point and those lessons
of the past few months so well learned
that I think it's going to say in the
memories of Americans for generations to
come
whereas I fear that for people from in
Holland for instance they will forget it
because it's easily taken care of by the
government and there's going to be a
time when welfare states in Europe will
not be able to pay for that amount of
government intervention
I will give you the example of the man
who murdered telephone girl who was on
welfare based on that principle 26
year-old healthy young man and what I
took from that and I think what many
Dutch people learned from that is he had
the time to plot Elida which in the
United States he would not be he would
be busy trying to feed himself and find
a roof over his head and so the idea
that the free market and makes the rich
richer the poor poorer that creates a
class antagonism and that that will
become a showdown between the two
classes and you're going to have the
crime rates go up and anyway the rich
people deserve it why don't they share I
think it's too simplistic and it's been
tried all over again it shows that
that's not really how it works
not only does it place government is
also far more efficient if a
philanthropic organization say the Gates
Foundation fails in its stated mission
it will correct itself much faster than
if this were a government you know if
that mission was run by a government
what you get in programs provided by
governments very often is an entrenched
interest comes about for the people who
are supposed civil servants and any
other group of people who have an
interest and so there's no point in
solving the problem the social problems
because if you solve those problems you
don't have that income from government
there's no need there's no reason for
you to exist and so I tend to agree more
with the Americans who are suspicious
about government and who say hey we are
going to take care of whatever social
issues that our country is facing by
collecting money and then by allocating
that money much more efficiently than if
it were government government in the
United States and anywhere else has been
planning public schools and just read
the history of public schools and I come
out thinking if this were I mean from
save our Gates Foundation that would
have made much much more sense